I'm shell Erickson I'm affiliate this
year with the agrarian Studies program
and the East Asian Studies program my
office is just upstairs I'm very happy
to present the final panel of the day
today we have three sets of scholars
will be presenting today first up will
be Colleen Boggs who is a professor of
English and Women's and Gender Studies
at my undergraduate alma mater of
Dartmouth College so to get things
started off Colleen Boggs will be
presenting so well thank you very much
for that introduction and I want to
thank the organizers for what truly has
been an extraordinary conference I know
that a lot of thought and work has gone
into it and it's been really privileged
to be one of the the beneficiaries in
terms of being here for all of these
wonderful talks over the past I guess
two days now and I'm truly honored to be
able to speak to you today in this in
this final panel of the conference the
title of what my talk is some Pig plus
sign exceptionalism and the bio politics
of Charlotte's Web some pig the pig I
referred to or rather the pig that
Charlotte's Web refers to that pig is of
course none other than Wilbur since e w
white published his novel in 1952 the
fame of any and all other pigs has been
eclipsed by this runt of his litter a
survey from 2000 listed Charlotte's Web
as the best-selling children's book in
US history and even recent Paul science
successes such as the 1995 film babe
will have a ways to go to dislodge
Wilbur from his position as the one Pig
that all Americans know Wilbur is also
increasingly the only pig they encounter
while there's already a nostalgia to zoo
Commons farm in 1952 the major
transformation in agricultural practices
had not yet occurred
the time of the novel's publication it
was between 1974 1991 that pig farms
vanished from the American landscape
under the pressure of agribusiness
consolidation in the largest peak
keeping region of the US the American
South more than 200,000 farmers were
driven out of business hand in hand with
that change also came the disappearance
of agricultural shows and the use of
pigs as pair ground attractions that we
see in Wilbur's exhibition at the fair
several scholars have read the novel as
complicit with the shift towards
large-scale factory farming and have
criticized the works focus on one Pig
salvation as sanctioning mass slaughter
and violence with the decreased
visibility of farms and pigs in the
American landscape the ongoing success
of Charlotte's Web is worth another look
as we assess the cultural frameworks for
our experience of pigs reading
Charlotte's Web through the lens of
so-called animal studies I argue that
the novel relates to crucial
philosophical and effective approaches
for engaging with pigs namely those of
bio power and intimacy Charlotte's Web
stages a drama of sovereignty that may
seem nostalgic but that is thoroughly
utopic an envisioning cross-species
intimacy as an alternative to death
oriented biopower EB White described his
novel as a pan to life a hymn to the
barn as such his novel is worth another
look part 1 biopower in chapter 9 the
miracle and I should give you a visual
in Chapter nine the miracle the web that
the spider Charlotte spins reveals words
for the first time some Pig however
those words are an echo of the novel's
first page when fern asks a mother why
her father is carrying an axe mrs.
arable replies that some pigs were born
last night and explains that the father
plans to kill the runt whereas mrs.
arable dismissively speaks of some pigs
in the plural as dispensable life
Charlotte's writing transforms that
dispensable life into exceptional life
some Pig is not the plural some pigs but
as singular and individuated in its
reference to Wilbur several scholars
have been critical of the novel on these
grounds they read this focus on an
individual and exceptional pig as
obscuring the plight of pigs in general
who are fattened and slaughtered give a
shout out you to Bret michelle's of
Bretton as outputs it these stories of
exceptional pigs either kept us pat so
somehow rescued from slaughter
ultimately serve as a palliative
exception that helps us forget that our
dominant relationship with pigs involves
killing and eating them in this context
it is worth noting that fern returns
from rescuing Wilbur to her breakfast in
a room that smelled of bacon saved from
slaughter stories stage the salvation of
individual animals and they are obscure
the fact that millions of anonymous hogs
and pigs are measured in the aggregate
and by the herd I find this a valid
reading of Charlotte's Web and yet the
novel also offers another interpretation
that makes a critical of rather than
complicit with this dynamic that other
interpretation hinges on the fact that
and here again I'm actually quoting Bret
mizelle humans power of a nature in
general and pigs in particular is made
possible in part by our belief in the
separation of nature and culture
Charlotte's Web opens with a critique of
that separation by revealing the power
dynamics that establish that to
separation between nature and culture in
the first place it plays out that
critique by across species intimacy's
that
challenge even curd animal studies
scholars to move beyond anthropocentrism
that is beyond privileges the human in
discussions of species scholarly
interest in bio politics and biopower
emerged in the early years of the new
millennium when scholars concerned with
the ethics of the so-called war on
terror looked towards michel foucault's
conceptualization for an analytical
framework well Foucault coined the term
by our politics and bio power and used
them to describe the reach of power into
life forms as such he never fully
developed the concepts in his work in
response to fucose work two major
schools of by a political theory have
developed mainly in Europe giorgio
agamben focuses on bio power as a
negative force tied to death by contrast
michael Hart antonio negri and Roberto
Esposito theorize an affirmative version
of bio power that contains revolutionary
potential for unsettling structures of
sovereignty given the fact that Wilbur
is an exceptional Pig by many scholars
accounts a goblins work on the state of
exception and the biopolitical use of
exceptionalism might at first plants
seem the more useful to invoke here so
let's explore that line of inquiry for a
Gambon the power to differentiate
between life-forms is key to the
exercise of sovereign power revitalizing
categories introduced by Aristotle
agamben argues that life is divided
between BIOS a political form of life
and Zoe a purely physiological form of
life Zoe is foundational to but excluded
from the political order for garmin
sovereignty is the exercise of
determining which life form counts as
bios in making that determination the
sovereign removes himself from bios and
occupies an exceptional position outside
of the law a position that is mirrored
by the so-called home osaka that is by a
figure of abjection that too is removed
from the law and subject to non
punishable and non more noble death well
for Gambon this process of
distinguishing BIOS from Zoe occurs at
the level of sovereignty and law giving
Charlotte's Web opens with a scene that
reveals the mundane live dimensions of
sovereignty that
every day species relationships the
novel begins with fern arable father
venturing forth to quote unquote do away
with a pig that is to kill it as turn
spells out when she correct some of us
euphemism fern does not merely interrupt
her father's fern does not merely
interrupt her father's exercise of human
sovereignty she draws attention to and
questions the very parameters by which
human and animal life are distinguished
from one another she asks her father if
I had been very small at birth would you
have killed me by the laws of species
sovereignty ferns questions absolutely
misguided as her father points out when
he says certainly not but this is
different a little girl is one thing a
little runty pig is another the
difference that mr. arable invokes is
one of species but also one of law not
only would it be illegal to kill fern
but the very notion of legality of the
law of species sovereignty depends on
the distinction between human and animal
however it is that distinction in the
grounds of law itself that phone
disputes when she replies I see no
difference and ties her remarks to the
question of justice and complaining that
this is the most terrible case of
injustice I ever heard of mr. arabel's
response is not what we might expect
instead of insisting on the distinction
between BIOS and Zoe that he was about
to perform he relinquishes in response
difference plea the queer look came over
John arabel's face and the queerness of
that look is tied to a fact he seemed
almost ready to cry himself the exchange
between father and daughter pivots on
notions of legality that are pitted
against senses of compassion miss
terrible relinquishes and it is not the
only time that fern finds an unexpected
Ally in her father phenomenal
representative of human sovereignty and
bio power on the farm the second time
mr. Ayer both sides with fern is less
physically dramatic but as significant
Charlotte's Web does not only reflect on
the material power of
animals but also engages with human
beings symbolic control fern that only
subverts the structures of sovereignty
and the distinction of human from animal
life she also questions the
communicative structures that grow from
and enable the biopolitical frame after
ferns account of the goings on in the
barn mrs. arable turns to our husband it
expresses her worry that fern believes
the animals can talk in response mr.
arable chuckles and replies maybe they
do talk I've sometimes wondered
unexpectedly he's ferns Ally not only in
suspending the exercise of bio political
sovereignty but also in extending the
symbolic frame to encompass animals as
participate participatory beings in
communicative structures that conceit of
animals participating in the structures
of symbol and meaning making is of
course the central conceit of
Charlotte's Web on the surface it seems
to be the ability for animals to
participate in semiotics that saves
Wilber and yet the novel ultimately does
not sustain that interpretation for one
thing fern and mr. arable have been able
to communicate with animals all along so
Charlotte's communicative act can come
as a miracle only to those characters
such as mrs. arable who have failed to
recognize this communication second
Charlotte's Web creates a sleight of
hand by which readers mistake signifies
for signifies and identify the
miraculous writing with the pig Wilbur
at an earlier point in his career EB
White had worked in advertising he'd
been a Don Draper of the 1920s so to
speak his early work at The New Yorker
often satirised advertising and that
satire is visible here as well then
third language and writing themselves
are ultimately in sufficient conditions
for Wilbur's removal from Zoe and
participation in bios even after
Charlotte's writing appears she feels
the urgency to keep writing what then do
these repeated acts of writing do that
the initial miracle could not perform
what is at stake in the repetition the
answer to these questions that the
heated act of writing brings together
and builds a community again and again
people travel to see and marvel at the
writing in the web again and again the
animals scramble to find words for
Charlotte to weave the community that
Charlotte's Web constructs cross a
species difference in two ways it is
built on the community between human
beings and animals that Wilbur in fern
first formed but extends to a community
among different animal species that
Wilbur constructs in the barnyard
Charlotte's Web is not just about the
drama of sovereignty it is about
replacing the drama of sovereignty with
the effective care of community part to
cross animal species intimacy and
affirmative biopolitics to develop an
analytical framework that ties this
reading of the novel truth intervention
into biopolitics the agha mian approach
doesn't offer us any answers especially
because as Timothy Campbell has pointed
out it is both d historicizing and
negative even tragic and tonality
Antonio negri as well as Roberta
Esposito a theorize a different form of
bio politics one that accentuates the
moment of resistance to power and has
the potential to create a revolutionary
horizon in the heart of empire for
Esposito that alternative depends on
exploding the compound that is bio
politics by creating a rupture between
biology and politics between bios and
politicals i want to read eb white as
envisioning this possibility when he
insisted somewhat paradoxically that
there is no political meaning in the
story if the drama of bio politics at
the novel stages is one that has no
political meaning then that is not an
abnegation of bio political significance
but an intervention into its frames and
parameters how then does white move from
by remove bios from politicals that is
how does he achieve Wilbur's salvation
from slaughter without replicating the
structures of exceptionalism that would
seem requisite under the a gambian frame
of sovereignty the kind of affirmative
biopolitics esposito imagines
is deeply utopian and that it
anticipates the coming of a virtual
community it is precisely that shift
from the actual to the virtual community
that Charlotte's Web stages with
Charlotte's death the actual community
that will burn she had constructed
disappears but it is replaced by a
virtual community that is in bands while
Charlotte's eggs are waiting to hatch
even when the little spiders appear they
represent the next generations as much
as the past generations they in stata
principle of communal renewal that does
not negate individuals but also does not
hinge or depend on them it envisions
something along the lines of what
Esposito and geo deleuze conceptualized
as an impersonal singularity a singular
and personality that is not to say that
the individuals or the collective are
dispensable not as the novel go as far
as deleuze and moving away from notions
of the subject the multitude of spiders
remains after all in relation to the one
and the only Wilbur and yet in the
novel's beginning Wilbur does not talk
and has no discernible perspective of
personality it is only when he moves
from ferns care to the barn that he
becomes Wilbur it is not individuality
per say then that the novel emphasizes
but individuation as a communal process
when Wilbur reflects that he's tired of
living his death oriented outlook
changes by the goose addressing him as
my friend my friend and it's my best
goose voice as white put it I think it
would be quite untrue to suggest that
barnyard creatures are dependent on each
other the barn is a community of rugged
individualists everybody mildly
suspicious of everybody else including
me whether we buy into whites
hermeneutics of suspicion or into the
novel's framing of relationship as
friendship in Charlotte's Web it is the
principle of community itself that
construct meaning and subjectivity that
does not make meaning and subjectivity
optional by the books logic community is
pervasive and expansive come
unity includes but does not privileged
human beings much work and animal
studies concerns itself with the
construction of relationships and yet
those relationships are almost
exclusively between human beings and
other animals so if we think about a
concept such as companion species one of
those companions always seems to be
human Charlotte's Web rarely considers
at sorry naturalist web this work in
animal studies rarely considers let
alone focuses on the relationships
between animals while Charlotte's Web
does not ignore the relationship between
human beings and animals and for that
matter facilitates it throughout for its
readers it also imagines relationships
among animal species as meaningful and
constructive of community and intimacy
it is that construction of cross animal
species community that allows the novel
to offer a new dimension to the field of
so-called animal studies whether by that
we mean the current theorization and the
humanities that have developed in the
wake of jacques de hadas last
publications or whether we mean the
activist strand that focuses on the
treatment of animals in conclusion
Charlotte's Web is a novel that
critiques structures of sovereignty and
imagines an affirmative form of bio
power that connects species as a pig
that is a domesticated animal that can
also be or even become feral Wilbur is
poised to serve as relay between the
world of humans and the world of animals
in a larger barnyard ecology that
imagines community as an intervention
into bio power and the site of
alternative subject formations
children's literature itself emerged in
the wake of John Locke's thoughts on
education Locke advocated two things one
literary instruction with child
appropriate materials for which you
recommended aesop's fables and to civic
instruction and kindness to animals
which would teach children to regulate
their despotic tendencies and make them
good citizens locks ideas gave rise to
the development of children's literature
in general and animal stories in
particular and Charlotte's Web is their
inheritor as much as their exemplar as
the novel says in its
illusion it is not often that someone
comes along who's a true friend and a
good writer Charlotte was both she
remained so two generations of child
readers yet perhaps the novel's most
valuable challenge to us as contemporary
readers lies in its imagining a horizon
of possibility a utopia by which current
forms of bio power may be superseded by
rethinking our relationship to animals
and validating their relationships to
one another that work remains to be done
thank you very much for listening